et il m'a il m'a beaucoup aimé parce
qu'il a dit que l'émission avait changé
sa vie et Yannick c'était un super
client ce que je me suis dit je me dit
il était top bon très bonne émission ça
a marché 1 200000 personnes étaient
devant il y a que la vérité qui compte
qui était qui a regardé hier Gill Verdez
ah Daniel bah toi tu as rien à [__]
euh non mais ah non mais c'est tellement
efficace quoi puis ça fait ça fait du
bien même de pleurer ça fait du bien
c'était c'est toujours rester
bienveillant malgré 20 ans plus tard les
réseaux sociaux et tout ça sur les
réseaux c'était que du positif enfin
vraiment carton plein non c'est tu as
regardé Flo non non non j'étais dans le
train d'accord ben très bien mon
ché ton
alibiout ça je quand même mais ça tient
bon on va parler d'une histoire beaucoup
plus triste 14 octobre 2022 la petite
Lola était tué dans le 19e
arrondissement de Paris cette affaire
avait ému le pays entier le corps de la
jeune fille avait été retrouvé sans vie
dans une valise son père s'est exprimé
dans une interview bouleversante sur M6
où il raconte sa reconstruction très
difficile depuis la mort de sa vie de sa
fille regardez ça fait un an et je suis
dévasté vous voyez comment je suis
aujourd'hui
ouais je suis dévasté avant le drame
bah j'avais une vie heureuse voilà avec
ma femme mes enfants ça faisait 20 ans
qu'on était à Paris dans le 19e on était
gardien d'Immeubles et on était
heureux
euh c'est vrai que c'est ça c'était une
affaire qu'on a énormément évoqué et
c'est vrai que quand je vois le papa
j'ai énormément pens et vous tous on a
pensé au aux parents de l'Ola c'est vrai
qu'on av on avait moins parlé de son
papa et là c'est vrai que ce
témoignage c'était céit incroyable que
s'est-il passé le jour du drame son père
raconte cette journée du 14 octobre 2022
où il a appris la mort de sa fille
regardez jusqu'au bout de ma vie
elle sera dans ma tête cette
journée c'est
impensable c'est une journée comme les
autres elle rentre toute seule du
collège elle a son badge elle a tout
sauf que là B il y a cette fille qui
passe devant qui rentre il y a ma fille
qui passe derrière
elle est rentrée à
15h27 puis c'est la dernière fois qu'on
la
voit et puis bah après bah il s'est
passé ce qui s'est passé on a retrouvé
ma fille à 23h dans une malle en
plastique c'est un SDF qui l'a retrouvé
voilà et une fois que tout bascule c'est
mais c'est une horreur c'est d'une
dignité d'une force la manière dont il
il fait si presque circonstancié comme
ça on sent sa peine c'est c'est
bouleversant voilà honnêtement c'est un
témoignage bouleversant d'une d'une
force incroyable incroyable alors il
raconte ensuite comment était sa fille
quelle relation il avait avec elle et
vous allez voir le prochain extrait
c'est il nous parlait de la la tueuse la
tueuse d'ababé était connue du quartier
mais le père de Lola n'aurait jamais cru
qu'elle tuerait sa fille ça le pire
c'est qu'il connaissait il il la
connaissait avant ça c'est c'est
incroyable
regardez cette femme non la connaissait
pas avec ma femme du tout parce que elle
était en souslocation je l'ai jamais vu
j'y souhaite même pas du malheur he
cette fille parce que bah parce que je
suis pas comme ça est-ce qu'elle va
prendre perpétuité est-ce qu'elle va
prendre que 5 ans j'en sais rien non
j'ai pas de souhait pour l'instant je
veux plus que ces choses-là arrivent
pour n'importe quel enfant voilà c'est
ça mon souhait que je veux aujourd'hui
alors ce qu'il disait en fait que je
disais qu' était connu du quti en fait
voilà on la connaissait dans l'immeuble
et C mais lui la connaissait pas il lui
a jamais parlé mais c'est dingue ce
qu'il dit parce que franchement c'est
fou de ne même pas comment il arrive à
être résilient c'est ça franchement il
dit qu'en fait il lu don il sera même
pas capable de lui donner une claque il
veut pas lui faire mal ce monsieur est
incroyable c'est respect absolu ah ouais
c'est un mais comment on peut imaginer
qu'elle prenne pas perpétuité en fait
c'est ça la question aujourd'hui c'est
sera-t-elle jugée ouais parce qu'elle
est en P exactement alors on peut faire
un petit point làdessus Paron a
énormément parlé ça nous a valu en plus
des des des des des sorties de
beaucoup de monde sur ce qu'on avait dit
sur ce plateau et bien elle est
hospitalisée euh elle est internée à
ville juif dans une unité de malade très
difficile où elle ne veut pas être c'est
c'est contre sa volonté mais en fait
elle pose d'énormes problèmes elle a un
comportement irrationnel irracible elle
ne dit pas vraiment les motifs elle
varie beaucoup alors elle est
l'administration pénitentiaire sait
qu'elle est là mais pour le moment on
n'exclut pas un retour en prison mais
aucune certitude voilà son état
psychologique est extrêmement fragile
elle est dans le dans le déniis parfois
dans le rêve dans la réalité il y a pas
de voilà il y a pas de suivi donc on ne
sait pas alors où on parle d'être dans
le déis pour potentiellement ne pas
aller en prison je dis pas ça j'ai dis
que pour le moment des expertises he il
y a des
expertises' vous plît s'il vous plaît ça
fait combien de temps depuis 14 octobre
2022 ouais c'est depuis février
l'hospitalisation non mais non mais 14
octobre 2022
it a perdu sa file 14 octobre 2022
combien là on est est un an après an
après ça elle est hospitalisée je crois
depuis février ou mars et la question
c'est le l'abolition du discernement
toujours la même question et surtout tu
dis qu'elle refuse d'aller dans cette
clinique psychiatrique mais elle veut
aller où en fait bah elle est en fait
elle est contre son gré c'estàd qu'elle
est agressive avec les soignants elle
pose d'énormes problèmes voilà contre
son gré non mais c'est c'est elle elle
elle ne elle n'accepte pas les soins
c'est ce que je veux dire je la je
justifie pas d'accord bien sûr mon g
bien sûr nonuss alors il raconte aussi
comment était sa fille quelle relation
il avait avec elle sa moment très très
fort de
l'interview Lola c'était ma petite peste
une fille joyeuse et puis
euh prête à courir partout elle voulait
être
infirmière après elle voulait être
soignante après euh elle voulait être
institutrice alors que l'école pourant
euh des fois euh enfin c'était pas son
truc mais voilà non ma fille qu'elle
aurait voulu faire dans le vie je pense
c'est apporter de l'aide aux gens voilà
ma fille c'est un amour voilà et et ça
restera toujours mon amour et elle vit
toujours pour
moi pardonnez-moi mais en fait quand
quand Gill tu dis peine en fait moi je
trouve que enfin il y a pas de mot en
fait on voit bien que la peine c'est pas
assez la rage c'est pas assez la colère
c'est pas assez je c'est insoutenable de
voir ce papa et qui malgré tout arrive à
être résilient et moi j'espère que la
justice sera à la hauteur globalement
dernièrement je trouve que la justice
n'est jamais à la hauteur elle est
souvent lâche elle est souvent elle est
souvent en dessous et voilà j'espère que
là elle elle pourra donner quand même
quelque chose un petit peu de dignité
àol elle est déjà elle est déjà pas à la
hauteur parce que 14 mois et laissé
cette famille là avec ce ressentil là ne
pas pouvoir s'apaiser c'est déjà une
jus combi combien de temps la justice il
lui faut du temps là il il a un collège
d'ext il va avir les experts se sont
beaucoup trompés
dernii malheureusement la justice ça
prend du temps et la première étape
c'est de connaître le discernement de
l'auteur des faits mais en tous les cas
ce que ça pose comme problème c'est que
peut-être qu'il n'aura jamais de
réparation et c'est absolument terrible
non mais peut-être on n sait rien mais
c'est absolument terrible cet homme
c'est une violence gratuite parce qu'il
y y a rien derrière c'est cette fille
s'en est pris à elle pour aucune raison
et donc sa fille est partie il est
extrêmement digne et peut-être qu'il y
aura jamais de réparation
Jud condamnation
à les victimes disent ement quand même
quand il y a une décision
Judici
incroyable est incroyable merci
Annabelle d'avoir été avec nous en tout
cas merci beaucoup merci et on va se
retrouver dans un instant n pour parler
de toute l'actualité bien entendu et on
aura
également on le savait on l'a pris voilà
il y a eu un drame bien sûr aujourd'hui
à aras on parler dans un instant à tout
de
suite
[Applaudissements]